we all know miami is a cultural melting
pot makes all the sense in the world
that we be able to celebrate bohemian
heritage night the junkanoo band is here
it should be a very festive atmosphere
we are looking forward to it tonight a
lot of energy in the ballpark and no
reason not to a very special evening of
course a little celebration of jazz
chisholm junior as well for the marlins
it's zach thompson his second major
league start he lost his debut at fenway
park
mel stottlemyer jr thought he might have
been a little tentative that first time
out a lot of minor league games first
big league outing fenway park full-count
pitch from thompson on the way and
that's cut on missed
a cut fastball from thompson
two-way right side marlon sav three
there jazz makes the play he's gonna get
a lot of cheers today that's for sure
they've got their hands full tommy max
freed goes to work for the braves coming
off a huge outing against the dodgers
great outing his last timeout check the
dodgers off the list now he's got to get
tomorrow his only team he hasn't beaten
his career you see his numbers last
seven starts have been great three and
three jazz chisholm junior to lead
things off again it figures to be a
really special day for jazz he's got the
family the entire family is here today
you see on the right uh waving the flag
that's grammy pat
that uh grammy pat coakley that's the
kind of the one that set it all up for
jazz chisholm jr and taught him about
the game of baseball back in the day
grandma judy chisholm is there as well
uh in the one of the 242 shirts there
but uh it's going to be an emotional
night one would think and maybe a little
extra juice for jaztime so we look
forward to that
good start
evening's ball game lead off walk for
jazz chance to add another with jazz
leading away from second one out in the
first inning free delivers and it kicks
away from contreras
goes near that opening next to the
braves dugout has to move up to third a
golden opportunity here in the first
aguilar out to center field and ciarte
underneath it gets a head start here
comes the throw from center jazz tags
and he's in there safely
really good growth from ncrt but better
speed from jazz and the marlins take a
one-nothing lead pure athleticism pure
speed from one of the fastest players in
the game
and jazz can do it all
talk about the bat so often the glove
how about the base running got a great
read great break and every inch mattered
2-1 de leon is lined to right gonna get
down for base hit sandy's been swinging
it better lately and he's got a
one-ounce single here to give the
marlins a one-out base runner in the
second inning
i mean it's that simple
it's that simple
slashing one into right field for his
first
i was sitting up here visualizing it i
wasn't sure how i was gonna say it to
you marlon's fans but i just kind of had
one of those feelings
he was gonna step in right because he
got his first big league start so he got
some action but he didn't get to hit and
he steps in today and i'm thinking
you know what just go for it swing hard
hope you run into something
as freed pops this one into left field
dickerson coming on he can't get it
that hit him in the forearm
and both pitchers have reached in the
game freed's aboard to start the braves
third inning
freddy shoots this one to right juval
turned the wrong way can't handle that
that ball drops safely at the warning
track on his way to third is max free
so freddie freeman finally has some good
luck hard hit ball dropped in right
field and they're at the corners with
one out
that's out into center field long run in
for marte he's going to get there loads
up and throws here it comes from center
and it's
on the mark what a throw from starling
marte
to cut down a run
a double play to get the marlins out of
the jam
now the gold glover in center field set
himself up well got momentum coming
forward
and a strong throw to sandy
just gets him on the left shoulder
02 freed to duvall and that ball is hit
well left center and deep and ciarte
back at the wall goodbye up onto
alternation alley
and it's two nothing marlins duvall the
former brave it's his fourth home run
his 11th rpi of the season against
atlanta
leigh diaz bats for him to start the
last of the fifth inning and lewin diaz
with a high fly ball this one is hit a
ton out to right and it's gone
a home run
diaz
not a bad spot to pitch it first major
league home run
as this one shot to left field there's a
base hit for freddie freeman good
approach ball got by dickerson freddie
is not going to advance he's there with
nobody out
to first aguilar goes to second for one
back to first a double play
so quick and getting rid of the ball and
getting rid of the responsibility watch
this little spin good throw then right
back to the back
he's on base streak is on the line
perhaps in this at bat and he got jammed
slow roller chisms got it stumbles fires
and safe hakuna lakes it out
and chisholm lands awkwardly and is slow
to get up
he did everything he could to beat acuna
at first
ronald was called safe
the marlins might challenge but remember
they used a challenge earlier in the
game i guess they're going to get an
umpire's review
to see if acuna did indeed beat the rap
at first base
which
i mean he's safe anyway he beat it i
thought it was at
at worst a tie heck of a play by
chisholm but ronald speed beat it keeps
that on base streak alive freddie
freeman has stung the ball twice singled
last time up freddie unloads deep to
right field that's down the line did he
keep it fair he did a two-run homer for
freddie freeman and here we come in the
eighth inning
it's a 3-2 game
freeman ranging way over
and marte beats it out
[Applause]
that's going to end up in center field
martay
was just more concerned with hanging
onto the second base bag than anything
else so
not going to third
aguilar check swing yeah that's right
that's going to get into right field
marta rounding third here comes no throw
from acuna junior another rbi for
aguilar
and the marlins now in front four to two
the 01 pitch to swanson to be awesome
how about awesome
with an unbelievable play over at third
side saddles that one gets up and throws
a strike over to first for the first out
a chopper to first backhanded by aguilar
gets to the bag
it's a marlins win
4-2 the final score they win the series
against the atlanta braves